[ __ ] ça plus jamais ce qui s'est passé il
s'en fout des règles elle
voulait aller d'un côté moi de l'autre c'est
toujours pareil mes meufs tu as écrasé
Cal on aurait pu exploser j'ai consulté
mon carnet ton carnet tu vas pas
dire  quoi que ce soit de merde qu'elle serait, c'est
que tout ce que tu veux que je dise je
ne te connais pas tu es en charge de la
sécurité ici que vas-tu faire ensuite l'
envoyer au lit sans dessert dessert tu
sais qu'il y avait un dessert ici mec  frère
tout était sous contrôle tu me connais
il n'y a rien de fou intuitif
peut-être mais pas fou Sophie il savait qu'il n'y
avait rien sous cette vache
c'était juste pour toi Sophie allez
Sophie elle est adorable et tu
n'obtiens aucun respect de sa part n'est-ce pas
je connais ce dessert content de n'avoir
plus qu'une semaine ici ce que c'est un mec je le
sais mec tu as dit bien sûr sur la vidéo
oh bien sûr ça pourrait être n'importe quoi ça pourrait
être un chien de gros cadavre soviétique est un
cadavre un chien mort n'est pas  un cadavre elle est
française de  un chien est un cadavre qui complète